are you daddy's boy Lucas Allen Geddes
adored his son Lucas a popular family
man but he was brutally murdered at the
hands of Stuart Quinn a violent serial
criminal with a history of psychotic
outbursts
someone who'd been released from prison
here in the northeast of Scotland just
hours before he stabbed Alan 40 times
came out in court that he was he had
been shouting for his family that his
family would would help
and and that that that rings in my ears
and it breaks my heart Stuart Quinn's
released from prison that day was both
unexpected and unplanned and it led to
him having a distressed state of mind
now a report sheds light on how the
authorities handled that release and it
paints a very Bleak picture it says that
he posed a risk of violence there was no
accommodation or care package put in
place and it concludes that that is
likely to have impacted the outcome
this report is a catalog of feelings
it's almost like we're enabling them to
go out there and do it because nobody's
nobody's doing anything about it
nobody's making a decision therefore
someone is either going to be hurt badly
or killed and your brother my brother
was the one that was killed yes this
report examines the Killer's
interactions with NHS mental health
teams in the 18 months leading up to the
murder it states aspects of that care
including how risks were assessed and
managed which have acted on might have
mitigated the risk of violence
systematic failures right across the
system it's quite clear that Stuart
Quinn should never have just been
released back into into society there
were gaps in the system to prepare
inmates for reintegration the process
suspended due to operational pressures
three months before Quinn was freed
authorities say an overhaul is coming
I'm angry now I'm angry the that um
my brother would still have been here
that um
it it was a it you know it was a it was
a a death that didn't have to take place
um my brother wouldn't have had to
suffer like he did
the officials involved have promised to
learn lessons Conor Gillis Sky News